the most cheerful philosopher maybe in
the history of philosophy most cheerful
philosopher in the book is is David Hume
and Hume is a fascinating example
because Hume is an atheist and dies as
an atheist Adam Smith in correspondence
with Humes doctor the word that keeps
coming up in that exchange is
cheerfulness Humes good-humour Humes
humor Humes whose cheerfulness and he
was visited on on two occasions by James
Boswell who was Samuel Johnson's
biographer because Boswell was offended
that Hume was going to go to his death
as an atheist he didn't believe that
Hume could go to his death as an
unbeliever
and Hume good-humouredly admitted him
they talked and Hume persisted in his in
his belief but he wasn't he wasn't mean
to Boswell and a sudden point it's
recorded somewhere that Boswell said to
him you know do you not at least
conceive of the possibility that the
soul is immortal and Hume said in
response if I throw a piece of coal on
the fire it is possible that it will not
burn and that is closest and so Hume I
wouldn't say is necessarily an optimist
but he goes to his death cheerfully for
me there's a correlation between
cheerfulness and pessimism you know it's
the pessimist who is the person who's
cheerful I have if you like Nietzschean
worries about optimism optimism is
usually bound up with an idea of the
future being better than things are now
which i think is is a risky thing to
believe for me it's about a
philosophical disposition is about M
Racing a certain pessimism that is not
negative but which is a condition for
cheerfulness and affirmation
I would I would maybe go for Epicurus
Epicurus as what he calls the tetra
farmer cost the four part cure don't
fear death don't fear God what is good
is easy to get and what is difficult
what is painful is easy to endure what
that thought is very interesting the
idea that one should not fear death I've
already I've already talked about you
know the point of being epicurean is to
accept the factor one's death cheerfully
without a longing for the free
multi-tier longing for the afterlife
don't fear God well there was no some
big angry vengeful garden for the
Epicureans gold was somewhere out there
but it wasn't really terribly important
what is what is good is easy to get on
what is painful is easy to injure when
most people think about
Epicurus and Epicureanism they think of
someone who's committed to pleasure it's
completely wrong
when Epicurus was asked what would give
him pleasure he said a bali cake and a
cup of water maybe with a pass of cheese
every now and then and that would be
more than sufficient
what it means meat epicurean is to
minimize one one two pleasures and to
focus on them as genuine pleasures and
if you minimize your pleasures you also
minimize your pains so the problem if
not the crisis that you know that we're
confronted with now is a crisis caused
by excessive excessive pleasures the
cultivation of excessive pleasures so
paradoxically at a time of crisis like
this might be one in which people can
learn to minimize their pleasures and
actually be happier in a strange way
you know points of points of crisis can
be philosophically interesting you know
we mean people were obviously living
through some sort of dreadful delusion
these last years about the future and
about the endless opportunities and
possibilities of the future a lot of
that has gone
that is an interesting philosophical
moment when that bubble is popped you're
left with you know you're left with
yourself and facing up to yourself you
can run away into religion if you like
that a consolation but it's a false
consolation you know when I was talking
earlier about the need to embrace the
transient and never occurring present
and that is the only eternity that's
available to us and that's something
which is very important you don't need
money to do that and I think you don't
need you don't need a crazy luxurious
lifestyle to do that in many ways you
know one of the interesting things you
can learn from the history of philosophy
is the importance of of poverty okay the
philosophers were often poor dodging
ease you know threw away threw away his
cup when he saw someone drinking with
their hands and why do I need that cup
right I could live without it so many
ways you know philosophy isn't isn't a
luxury add-on to culture for me it's
something which can allow one to accept
you know the less is more in a strange
way